exactly you can convict that dude from
being a murderer thank you now the
evidence is right there in your face
right what the [ __ ] is you want me for
because this is what he felt he felt
like i'm supplying a whole bunch of dope
and [ __ ] over there and and trying to
make the blood car strong that was his
big
[Music]
here we are in ohio the deer lodge um
guys i can't tell you how much it means
to me that you both are here you both
are uh unbelievably uh dear friends of
mine bo you know we've gotten to know
each other this past year and um i met
you the first time um down the pueblos
the respect and love that you get from
that community
uh is is staggering to me uh
but i think even more so is what you
give back you know you're bold and
you're hungry and you're brave and um
i'm just uh i'm proud man i'm proud to
call you a friend and j man you know
it's uh
you know it's been more than 10 years
yeah you know met you on a ride-along
down in in newton south central um i
i've been lucky enough to to to hang out
with a lot of uh people who really
you know walk the walk don't just talk
about it and and folks in law
enforcement and um your you're you're
top billing for me man i've never seen
someone who gets the kind of respect and
love uh
from both the community and other
officers and um you give respect you get
respect i've seen you in action man and
i've seen you um again treat everybody
with respect but be willing ready and
able to take it to any level that
somebody wants to take it and it's
taught me a lot uh and and made me a
better man and a better father and uh i
love you man and i'm really grateful
that you guys are here and and you know
i want to i want to kind of get into
sort of your lives and like how you guys
got to the place you are some of your
experiences and um i guess bo i want to
start with you man like can you just
tell me a little bit like i you know i
mentioned before how how important to me
sort of your neighborhood is but can you
just tell me a little bit about uh
the pueblos and like what it means to
you and coming up where you did i know
you bounced around a lot but can you
just sort of talk about that community a
little bit i mean you know i'm really
born and raised there man you know it
wasn't
long that i you know anytime i left it
wasn't too long you know i was always
back you know my mom my family friends
everything always was down there you
know so i was breaded there man you know
and
and through life you know as you grow up
and you know you do some things in your
life you make bad decisions and
it wells on you and when you get a
chance and you mature at the mind man
and you see what's going on around you
you know you feel like it's kind of like
it's your job man cause i love that
place man i love everybody and to give
back to give back yeah you know tell us
specifically for people don't know like
what neighborhood are you from i'm from
the pueblo del rio housing projects and
public bishops
and that's in uh and that's in south
central los angeles eastside east side
of los angeles what was it like there
sort of as a kid like how would you
describe that community and as a kid man
actually it was family orientated you
know what i'm saying um
you know we was back in the days where
you can get your ass with a extension
card uh
a switch a belt you know and it wasn't
no big deal you know you're not you
weren't going to go to jail for child
abuse and things like that you know and
if the neighbor down the street caught
you doing something and you was out of
line they can whip your ass take you
back home and then you'll get another
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so you
know it was it was kind of family
orientated man and you know you you grew
up and back then in those days you know
it was like mainly like a lot of black
families there man you know what i'm
saying so it was kind of understanding
you know what i'm saying and and what
would you say is the biggest kind of
like
misconception of you know south central
back then you know i think the biggest
misconception back there was about was
probably that we didn't give a [ __ ]
about each other over there you know
what i'm saying
and that only the gangs cared about each
other and and
you know in that it wasn't people that
was really trying to to grow and get out
and you know and become something and do
something over there you know i think
that
that everyone was labeled the same there
you know y'all are who y'all are y'all
here so everybody is a [ __ ] criminal
over here you know what i'm saying and
and which wasn't true you know i'm
saying being there living there and
growing up there you know by far that's
far from the truth you know what i'm
saying back in those days it was a lot
of uh police raids you know it's the
neighborhood so people gonna hang out
you're gonna see people drinking you're
gonna see people listening to music
you're gonna see people probably just
gambling are you gonna just see people
in a huddle talking and everybody that's
around there is not wasn't doing what
they was perceived to be doing you know
what i'm saying so when the raids come
it's just like if you out there you
caught up in it you [ __ ] up and the
[ __ ] up part about it was
you just happened to get caught in the
wrong spot where somebody threw
something or some [ __ ] like that that
was yours you know what i'm saying so
it puts you in that mentality man where
you know it's like [ __ ] it it's wild
wild west then you know what i'm saying
you don't [ __ ] over me and gave me a
record now and shit's gonna be hard and
you know you and and it's times like
that that make you feel like that
society is against you you know what i'm
saying to make you get that i don't give
a [ __ ] type mind you know what i'm
saying now some people was out there
doing it some people did have certain
things that they didn't want to have out
there you know what i'm saying but
everybody didn't i know you know people
attribute so much about south central at
that time
you know in the 90s and the 90s um with
the bloods and the crips and all that
just talk about sort of your
relationship with that and that how that
started and and what like kind of like
led you that way well you know my
relationship i always had always been
affiliated with the pueblos you know
what i'm saying that's my family that's
my first family and i'll do anything and
and go through you know any loops for
this guy you know what i'm saying and
that's how it started man because you
don't you don't
come out the wound saying this pueblo
bishop blood
you don't you know you come out the
wound
being a kid
you know you're gonna do the kid [ __ ]
and y'all gonna become good friends
during that childhood you know what i'm
saying the way l.a is set up
and if i was born and raised in the
pueblos whether i got now tattooed or
wore a now red rag or ever hollered
blood out of my mouth i'm labeled as a
pueblo
so i can't go
on
across lawson
and hang out and chill and say i'ma stay
away from the pueblos because it's
gangbangers over there because you're
gonna get killed over there because they
know that you was born in the pueblos
you cannot be safe and hang nowhere
unless you in your neighborhood you know
even though you're not a blood
you know what i'm saying
you can't just go to any neighborhood
and hang out and feel like you're safe
because they know from school sports or
whatever else oh that's the dude from
the pueblos he's from the pueblos
and so if you're a [ __ ]
automatically that's a problem and like
for my case man
it's more or less that i chose
you know
to do what i do man you know what i'm
saying i chose it because
you try to be right you try to do right
and it just seemed like
it ain't enough you know and then you
get to that point where
you know like you say you feel like
society is heavy on you you know what
i'm saying well they labeled me this
they put me as this i'm gonna be this
and you fall into that trap man and so
you know you just get to this point like
i'm in it to win it can you think of
like the first sort of thing to you that
that that really um
sort of set that off on you and so sort
of emblazoned you into that into that
world and into the blood specifically
well man you know like i said man it's
just it's always been my family over
there but
you know it's the incident where we're
hanging out on long beach and
you know we just
maxing doing doing what we do you know
on the daily just as homies you know
what i'm saying
and standing there two cars ride by
and you know they just start spraying
bullets well in the midst of that
lost the homies standing you know right
there
with me one guy shot one got killed
and so
you sitting there you looking at that
you see the whole thing go down because
all you do is duck and
certain people trying to run certain
people trying to duck so you know hiding
but you kind of looking and trying to
see where it's happening and you just
you see it you see it everything you
know and he dropped right in front of
you you know what i'm saying you looking
and you got you know
you're helpless you can't do nothing all
you can do is wait till it's over and
then try to see what's going on but you
get over there then it's too late you
know what i'm saying
and when you see it you know that type
of [ __ ] happened man you know it changes
something in you
you know and you could choose to leave
and never come back or
to get in the fight
so i'm still in the pablos
when you say it um
what do you think it is that like makes
that when when you say it changes
something in you uh
you know can you just can you just like
describe can can you just kind of walk
me through that a little bit
i mean man you know like i said when i
say change to something in you man it's
you know
when you watch somebody you grew up with
and did all the things you did as a
child get dropped right in front of you
you know you you
come on man you know you you want
you know what i'm saying yeah you know
and and so you know like i say you know
your whole mentality change you know
and you uh
you know you make
certain decisions in life that ain't
healthy for you my mother was sprung out
on crack crack cocaine man you know what
i'm saying
my father wasn't around a lot most of
the men i dealt with in my family was
probably my uncles
you know what i'm saying and my homeboys
and the killing part about it
whether you know it or not
when you going to school and you playing
ball and you doing and you see your
homies that's banging and selling dope
and [ __ ] man they don't tell you to come
out there and sell dope for them right
they don't they try to keep you away
from the block but you ain't trying to
hear that [ __ ] because you want to do
what you want to do and they literally
chases you off the block
they tell you man keep doing what you're
doing you don't need this like like i
never ever ever had not one homeboy
while i was playing ball and doing my
thing say [ __ ] the sports
come out here and be a blood and sell
this dope with us
ever in my life and i swear that on my
children
not one time have i ever in my life told
a youngster that
i can't remember a time in my lifetime
where one of my homies and said well the
homie told me stop playing ball and come
out there and sell dope right that's
[ __ ] man right right the homie
forced me to be a blood no
right it don't work like that because we
were family before we were anything
before you represent any color any block
any number any anything we were all
family
and you know so it's like man more of
the so the love that you get man you got
to think man it was a lot of fatherless
kids over there man
a lot of mothers who got caught up in
that crack you know epic that pen you
know the whole thing with the with the
crack [ __ ] man you know what i'm saying
and you you seeing your mother out on
the block pushing carts and all kind of
[ __ ] can't pay rent getting kicked out
you know and you can't go nowhere once
your mom get kicked out of them projects
where else can you go and hang besides
them projects and that was the thing you
were stuck there man you know what i'm
saying unless you can figure out with
minor education how to
to get a job and and get your credit up
and that [ __ ] man
we wasn't thinking about that [ __ ] back
then bro you had to be fortunate and
lucky to [ __ ] go somewhere where
somebody can give you the advice to even
think about start talking about credit
and buying a house in college and all
that [ __ ] and i imagine at that time in
the 80s and 90s and and and jay that's
you know a good way to bring you like
you're talking about a a time period and
a place that was extremely violent you
spent the vast majority almost all of
your career in newton in that same
neighborhood just tell me just just a
little bit about um
you know tell me a little bit about your
family and then sort of like about you
know coming into newton
yeah i mean my dad was a you know he
worked for the studios for for a while
then he decided to open his own business
like construction
business and he did you know marble
counters marble bathtubs and you know he
was one of eight so we had lots of
cousins and stuff and most everybody at
one time worked for my dad you know
either pushing a broom or installing or
whatever and uh
he moved us
from van nuys out to northridge
and uh i think it was more just to kind
of keep us away from
what he had seen he's the youngest so
you know a couple's brothers were bad
a couple were good
so he's like hey you know i got the
opportunity
the houses were cheap out there at the
time i think they paid like 22 grand for
our first house you know and that's [ __ ]
um
so so we moved out there and you know
again 22 grand that time is a struggle
you know it's the mid 60s when we moved
out there
and um so i was kind of pulled away from
that uh
we didn't see any violence you know
high school junior high high school
there'd be a few fights you know
and uh and that was it but
my uncles would you know we'd see him at
family gatherings and my dad like hey
stay over here you know blah blah blah a
couple of both been in and out of prison
one was paralyzed he was uh i think 1968
he was shot by the police when he was he
was trying to escape court he had you
know he was in court for a robbery he
had a dope problem he was shooting
heroin
and so he tried to make a run
out of the courtroom
and back then uh yeah you know hey i
don't mean it
man
do crazy [ __ ] right and so he's going to
[ __ ] run out of court
and get away well back then fleeing
felon was a fleeing felon that was a
shoot you know cops could shoot you for
that [ __ ]
so he he makes it out and down the
hallway and the cop catches him running
down the hallway and shoots them
and paralyzing them so knowing that the
police shot your uncle did that color
your opinion of police at that time well
you know we didn't find out
again my dad trying to keep this [ __ ]
away from us hey what happened to you
know what happened uncle sabino ah he
got a car wreck man he's paralyzing him
okay you know went through the
windshield i'm like you know wear your
seatbelt yeah all right dad whatever and
then it took a while
for us to finally find out what happened
you know and i'm like but what do you
think about that i mean sort of like to
kind of like what what
what beau was talking about i mean had
you found out about that at that time in
your do you think that that would have
like colored your
so
you your your image of the police or
would it you know i don't know because
my dad was like hey you [ __ ] respect
the police if he goes if you go to jail
for fighting or doing some [ __ ] i'll
come get you but if you go to jail for
some [ __ ]
[ __ ] selling dope or [ __ ] with
these guys these dope ass i'm not gonna
get you you know like okay he goes just
[ __ ] do the right thing and then my
mom's brother he was a policeman
and [ __ ] he's you know six four
and he's just a big a big figure you
know he would take his camera don't be
[ __ ] around and he had three boys so
my best buddy growing up um
he
got uh he went to the sheriff's
department
and i was at the time i was like you
know uh [ __ ] 20 or 20 was working for my
dad
and [ __ ] man it's just
hey dad [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
guys doing here get the [ __ ] get off the
[ __ ] desk get on the [ __ ] broom
hey do this do that and you know he was
a yeller you know
and but
he liked his beer and and uh
you know every day he
he'd [ __ ] drink and so
we'd shoot home and or whatever and
you know he'd [ __ ] show up 10 30 11
sauced or whatever but
his his work ethics were were [ __ ]
second to none no matter how [ __ ] up
he would be drunk hungover
six a.m man he's up showering and out
the door back to work you know so we all
worked for my brother worked for him my
cousins worked from
but i was like man this is [ __ ] it's
a good business but
i can't stay here man
yeah
for all this time so
that's when my buddy joined up with the
sheriff's i'm like well [ __ ] the
sheriffs i don't want to go to shares
you know i don't want to be in the jails
for two or three years so
um i applied for
lapd and i applied for burbank pd i got
hired right before christmas uh 87 so i
was gonna start in january 88 and then
[ __ ] two days after i got hired for lapd
burbank calls hey well you know we got a
spot for you i'm like oh i'm good but i
got sent on probation
after the academy to north hollywood
which it's time you know you have
a
lower class up in the north end trouble
you have a lot of cocaine a lot of
heroin up there
the regular middle middle class working
joe's stuff not very many problems and
then you have the rich down there
ventura boulevard which you'd hardly
ever get any calls
and so
i got a chance to work with some
different guys i liked working in the
north end because it was busier you do a
lot of observational rest a lot of work
you know you're shaking the bushes and
doing this stuff
but there were some [ __ ] absolute
lazy [ __ ] guys that didn't want to do
[ __ ] you know and then i got assigned to
the the south end car
and i'm like all right great you know
and you know you're a young cop you want
to [ __ ] chase everybody chase bad
guys and chase this and that and
it gets signed down to ventura boulevard
right like all right you know probably
find something to do down here and
all right kid let's go to the coffee
shop
all right
so you're gonna get get your coffee and
you know we'll roll out of there right i
don't know i just sit out here by the
car
so another car would show up and they'd
sit there for [ __ ] two hours
what the [ __ ] we're gonna do man [ __ ]
the [ __ ] going on out here man
that i just you know don't worry about
it
all right he goes all right
let's go up to vent uh let's go up to
mulholland right
so we go up to mulholland he'd pull over
but this time was like 2 33 in the
morning he was all right man
pull over all right
okay i want you to go from coldwater
canyon to the border of hollywood
don't drive over 20 miles an hour
okay what are we looking for cause i'm
gonna take a nap
i'm like you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ]
me just wake me up at six wow and i'm
like goddamn is this what is is this
[ __ ] police work man what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] man
and uh six o'clock [ __ ] hey hey boss man
and uh he pressed the station go ahead
let's go to the station
i'm like
[ __ ] we didn't do [ __ ] dude
i don't worry about it i got something
to do today you know he wanted to go
play golf in the morning or whatever so
you you would get
it was good in a way you got
different variations of coppers i mean
most guys were vietnam vets
and those guys some of those guys man
they wanted to work they wanted to work
so we go out boom boom boom boom you
know and we'd stay busy until 3 4 in the
morning i learned how to do dope i
learned how to do hypes you know these
guys were were teachers
and i'm like you know hey what else do
you want to do i haven't done this can
we try this and he goes okay you know
let's try that let's let's go and he
shows me how to read you know the needle
marks and watch people's eyes and i'll
show it was an education
you know and you just sit there you're
like a sponge man you take it all in
because i wanna i wanna do this i wanna
learn i wanna be able to know how to do
all this stuff so you got guys that you
love working with and guys that you
didn't but you can't say [ __ ] you're on
probation you know
and so after
uh probation then i went to newton in uh
june of uh 89. so june of 89 newton
south central so what what what what was
your first impression of that [ __ ] this
place stinks it's the the rendering
plant the parmesan rendering plants just
in the city of vernon there
and man i know you know that smell man
because it's on those hot sticky nights
summer nights
it just it's death
it smells like [ __ ] death
and it we're in the old station it was a
piece of [ __ ] station it was built in
i don't know 20s or 30s right
and um the first three nights i was
there was five murders right and i'm
like
what the [ __ ] is going on man and what's
the stigma i mean like
as a police officer what's the stigma of
a newton cop you know shooting newton
like what would other police say about
newton cops and what would they say
about newton especially at that time you
either love it or you hate it
and you would stay forever or you left
within a couple months it just wasn't
for you exactly and you see guys come in
and they're like [ __ ] this place i'm
going to the valley man i could have
nice restaurants to eat you know people
love us out there i mean [ __ ] we drive
down central we got tams
uh you go over to figueroa you go to
[ __ ] beef bowl
i mean just like [ __ ] places you know so
like okay whatever and um and it was
busy
if you're at newton you're working
you're working they want hard workers
and sure there was a few slugs there you
know i mean it's going to happen but
most of the time guys hustled [ __ ]
step it up or get the [ __ ] out of here
because it's so busy there was such a
high volume of cost this is so and it
was a
intensely violent uh time yeah a man
with a gun there was a man with a gun
you know and shootings were going off
all the time crack was huge it just
really
uh
[ __ ]
mid 80s i think it really started
popping off with the rock back then they
would hold it man you'd get them with
bags of dope and [ __ ] by as time has
evolved everybody's learned everybody
learns you know and
from coppers to bad guys is you know hey
don't be holding [ __ ] 20 rocks on you
man and ultimately you you joined crash
yeah i got in the crash uh in uh 90 in
like may april or may of night can you
just explain so crash was uh criminal
resources against street hoodlums which
is what they're gaining it
and so you're
responsible for gang intelligence
responding to gang-related crimes
gang investigations so you would
be expected to know who's who in the
neighborhood so each each officer kind
of had their own gangs that they like
working
so i would be over on the west side of
the division
certain hispanic gangs and as you go
further south we get into some of the
black mostly crips because the only
bloods in in newton were
um
down in the pueblos or the bloodstone
villains and then i think there were
some up in the rolling 20s 30s
and 40s
yeah 40s so a small a group around the
station
but i was most the time over
dealing with either broadway's fort
deuce fortress cribs
avalons and east coast cribs so that was
my thing kind of working on the on the
uh on the west side of the division and
then certain guys like working in
pueblos and you know you know i mean you
see the same faces over there all the
time can you remember sort of your first
interaction with the police you know
what was your sort of attitude towards
them
i i never trusted police because i i
just
seen some of the [ __ ] they did but my
first reaction i was still in high
school
and by this time i had went down to stay
with my grandmother
in oregon
so it was uh summer
came back to l.a you know happy
playing ball and
you know just
glad to be back and see my friends
it was after i made it from the bus
station i just made it to my mom's house
i put my bags up and everything and i
started walking uh
to the neighborhood to pebbles through
the park when i got through the park
a car came up
and three dudes jumped i'm like they
were like put your hands on your head
and this i'm like what you do well for
what you know i'm what what happened
and then he grabbed me and slammed me
and put his knee all in my neck and [ __ ]
and and handcuffed me and the first
thing you told me what they call you
over here
[ __ ] you mean what they call me over
here they call me nut and they call me
my name dante
no
take his shirt off lift my shirt up
start looking around everything like man
what the what's up
where you going they searching looking
all through the bushes everything and
everything and all that
ran my name all that [ __ ] happening by
this time it was a whiff of it that got
back to my mother now so everybody knew
that you know i ain't been there i've
been going to school you know trying to
do something out of town so a bunch of
crowded people coming what the [ __ ] is
y'all doing with him he ain't even over
here like you know they just making a
you know big deal because they [ __ ]
they roughing me up you know what i'm
saying they swearing up and down i'm a
gang member
so i didn't know nothing about the white
card and all that and they telling them
he's not a gang member don't put him in
there as a what's a white card a white
card is this information they get from
you
and they put all your information on
this card and they put you as a pueblo
gang member and that's what that's what
the crash guys are trying yeah so you
have a little uh three by four cards fi
card field information card name you
know social phone number address all
that [ __ ] and there's section
uh gang
and then uh aka moniker whatever like
that
so you know it was like you know that
[ __ ] pissed me off i had a tear dropping
on my eye
man you know because i'm like what the
[ __ ] is that just came from
being in school and i'm going to see you
know hang out
i don't care what the [ __ ] going over
here what made you come grab me and slam
me on the ground
just because i'm asking what's going i'm
i'm scared really i'm scared man cause
they jump out get your [ __ ] hand turn
around and all
you know they like make sure y'all run
you know and that incident from right
there had me running from the police all
the time
all the time i'm not feeling when i see
them coming i'm not going to sit up
there and tell me to get on my knees and
all that you know i'm [ __ ] all that
you finna do your job [ __ ] with me
it's gonna be a foot race
and more than all the time i won
like how often when you stop somebody
would they run
oh i mean back then back then i i mean
you'd crack the door and [ __ ] the
[ __ ] you see the bottom of their
tennis shoes rolling you know so
in our minds that motherfucker's heated
up man you know or he's got something on
him but a lot of times like you say man
i'm like man i i got my clean [ __ ] out
i'm not about to get [ __ ] up put on
the put on the doubt on the ground and
my clothes ruffled that's the mentality
of the folks that you're dead that's the
mentality of folks because everybody has
a different way of working by knowing
the people and getting to know people
it's a little easier but
that's like
experience you gather over time you know
and that's why they would always put you
with a an older guy
that knows the neighborhood or but who
that older guy is is so unbelievable
some guys just hundred percent some guys
are evil and vile and want to go [ __ ]
people yeah you know some people are
really trying to make a difference
absolutely so can you give me an example
of that yeah i mean i worked with the my
first partner um
he he passed away he got killed uh
up on highway 138 they were they were
transporting uh
somebody for witness protection out to
uh out to victorville area out there and
him and his partner were coming back
and uh wrong way
[ __ ] head on
and ended up killing him and
the other guy was with he's he got
[ __ ] up pretty good and so lapd had a
list of 44 right the most
uh violent or complained of officers for
uses of forces and stuff and he was on
that list his temple was about [ __ ]
that long right you learn um
some of the [ __ ] what to do and some of
the [ __ ] of what not to do
and so
he was good with
picking out dopers and and [ __ ] like
that and then my next partner who
uh i i got to work with he was good with
guns you know and he's like hey look for
this look for that
this is where they hide guns this is how
they you know
they're always checking and they're
always like if they cops you know you
see a cop car rolling up they'll [ __ ]
kind of like
just casually check make sure the gun's
not showing you know and we got a lot of
guns you know it was it was a real good
learning experience
and
he treated people a little bit different
you know
he knew a lot of people
and a lot of times we'd grab [ __ ]
take them back to their mama's house and
mama would whoop that ass because i mean
there's a there's a us versus them
mentality that that causes all kinds of
i i think yeah you know like his his
[ __ ] he comes back to newton's first
experience just throwing them on the
[ __ ] ground so [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna be
pissed off man
you know i know you get that yeah you
know i'm like all right i mean i get
that dude
not everyone's bad
but
it takes a time for these guys and i'm
not making an excuse for anybody there's
[ __ ] [ __ ] cops just like there's
[ __ ] people out there
and like [ __ ] you need to
[ __ ] learn
who's right and who's wrong and the only
way you're gonna do that is talking to
somebody you know so we'd roll up on
somebody and if they give us [ __ ]
attitude and this and that oh [ __ ] you
man [ __ ] him like all right bro it's
cool man we ain't got nothing you know
like all right you wanna be an [ __ ]
cool and a lot of times they'd be
showing off you know because you catch
them alone hey man i'm sorry man but i
couldn't you know the [ __ ] homies are
there man i can't
you know i can't be no punk man but you
know i'm sorry you know and [ __ ] like
that so
you get it you learn and then going over
and over these neighborhoods you see the
same cats and you know like [ __ ] that's
you know that's a bad [ __ ] so we
rolled through broadway hood you and i
yeah that one night yeah and there was
this one cat from broadway's
and
he would never talk to the police you
know and we knew he was running the
operation and [ __ ] but like i said man i
don't catch you dirty i don't catch you
you know
you know he was smart he was a smart cat
and so we're talking to one gangster and
as we drive away
he walks back over this guy and he slaps
the [ __ ] out of him right
and i'm looking in the mirror like okay
all right he just got disciplined man
for talking the [ __ ] police man
because you know i mean the biggest
thing in anything is a [ __ ] rat man
you know on both sides [ __ ] police
[ __ ] gangsters criminals
nobody wants to [ __ ] deal with a rat
or even think you're dealing with a rat
you know so yeah we had to be careful
you know you get caught that's that
other side of of of loyalty right i mean
i would imagine in both sort of
institutions it's like there's a
currency for being loyal man like you
got to be loyal you got to be the kind
of person who's i mean you're judged on
your actions not on what you
say and do you think that there's any
kind of dark side to loyalty or are
these sort of expectations of being
there for somebody where it actually
makes you do do things that aren't good
for either one of you the beautiful side
to it is you know
it's just when you were in need and i
ain't talking like money or whatever you
know it's it's
for instance man
if i'm at the movie theater me and two
homies
and
15 10
you know
the other guys come in and i'm stuck
there
and you make that phone call and before
you know it it's about 30 [ __ ]
and came up there and making sure you
get out of there safe you know that's
that beautiful side 200 that's the side
that make you want to stay loyal to it
like man they love me they put their
life on the line these [ __ ]
stopped everything and came up here for
me just off of my phone call you know
what i'm saying
then the other side is yeah it is you
know you get caught up in the trust game
so hard and you really don't see what's
going on you know and whether you know
like for instance you know selling dope
and getting money was a big thing in
their 80s you know and 90s so you know
you have some [ __ ] that's going
to cross you you know it's some homies
that didn't die like that because other
homies then came back and robbed him and
did [ __ ] you know and you know or just
the dude that you thought was solid
told and you you know you
[ __ ] you had to go do a bid you know
what i'm saying so it's it's yeah it's a
good side and a bad side to it man but
you know i mean that's
the way of life you know specifically
over the last you know couple years with
with sort of the anti-police movement
and all this sort of like the police
being under the scrutiny that they are a
lot of the issues that have been coming
up is really because of this loyalty is
because okay i see
there's this officer with his knee on
this
this man's neck and they're dying but
they don't want to cross a line they
don't want to be disloyal or they don't
want to act out of so they're not doing
anything about it i think that that's
the real toxic side i mean wha what do
you think about that yeah i mean you
know that that incident there and i'm
looking at that [ __ ] and i'm like what
the [ __ ] are these guys these other guys
doing
why is he down there you got a crowd of
people i i mean get that cat up and get
them in the [ __ ] car
what the [ __ ] are they doing standing
there man
you know and i'm like you're just as
much as fault because you're not doing
anything
and even though that they were sort of
younger officers and but what's right is
right what's right is right you know and
and that's real courage right yeah
that's real hey man i'm not gonna sit
here and watch this [ __ ] copper beat
the [ __ ] out of somebody with handcuffs
on and that was my big [ __ ] deal once
it comes around that's it man but that
[ __ ] went on though no absolutely that's
no 100
and i mean went on man 100
and i'm not gonna sit here and debate
that man because
that's you know
it happened and that was the [ __ ] up
part about it that's the part that make
you say [ __ ] the police man for real and
the worst thing is to run and get caught
oh yeah if you run and get caught
guaranteed you just you just know you
already know that's why [ __ ]
used to try so hard to make sure they
get away that's why i was through any
means necessary i don't care if you got
to run through three tigers a lion and a
a gorilla right you're going to try to
get away because you know if they catch
you make them run yeah and or if you
hide and they
call a helicopter in the forest you know
that dog coming you know all that so you
you trying to just get away you don't
want to get stuck nowhere and be nowhere
man because you know that ass gonna get
whooped you know what i'm saying and
then don't try to fight back that ass
gonna get stumped you know what i'm
saying it was a [ __ ] up feeling man
because sometimes you really ran because
you just didn't want to deal with the
[ __ ] man it's like man when would when
are they gonna figure out that god damn
everybody ain't doing wrong so why you
gotta jump out and make me get on my
knees or squeak put my fingers together
and squeeze the [ __ ] real hard and
pull me back and you know just all this
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that hurt you don't want
you're not experiencing you don't want
it no but you don't want it time and
time and time sometimes you just go
through the process cause you just
staying up for it you know you clean you
know you you know and the [ __ ]
that dirty most likely to run or the
people that just don't want to do it
they're gonna run but if you stay there
and they run
you still get the treatment so you was
gonna lose lose no matter how i go
so you know you had no sympathy for
police
because this is what was going on for
years on top of years on top of you no
matter what you was trying to do if you
was there you was there and you probably
a [ __ ] up individual to them
if they don't know who you are and they
didn't know who you are yeah i mean you
roll up on a a group of guys and one guy
[ __ ] bones out and i [ __ ] man i can't
catch that [ __ ] you know
even when i was running all the time man
i'm [ __ ] man i can't run dude i had one
guy he was a he was a good runner i like
hey man just [ __ ] catch him and wait
till i get there bro you know and
[ __ ] chasing [ __ ] and
[ __ ] i catch up after a minute you know
and and uh
but like you say man no i i totally get
it man and and that's just the way
uh i like these pursuits you see these
[ __ ] pursuits on tv now [ __ ]
are hanging out of the cars and [ __ ]
filming themselves and going live and on
facebook and all this [ __ ]
like man those [ __ ] would have
got tuned up back in the day i think
part of what we're talking about here is
like stigma right and that you're just
hanging out with some guys on a block
whether whatever period of time in your
life but there have been people who have
just been out on a block and that have
been forced to be in these humiliating
and painful situations for no reason
whatsoever except for the color of their
skin the neighborhood they happen to be
in that's not fair it's un-american
right but at the same time there's a
stigma attached to police officers in
general
around this country whether you engage
in that kind of behavior or not you're
made to feel like the enemy when you're
also uh engaging in an unbelievably
high-risk job um you've you've probably
lost people that you care about the same
way that you care about your homeboys
you i mean i know you've lost people and
you've been shot at and that feeling
that that that's not
fair
um i i i it exists on on on both sides
of this absolutely and i i think you
know you see [ __ ] on the on the news and
you see [ __ ] that's videotaped and
you're like
[ __ ] me dude it's it's coming now you're
gonna it did now we're gonna pay for
this for months until the next incident
happens it's [ __ ] business man it's
not [ __ ] personal and when it goes
over to that personal side that's when
you have problems as you know
you know when it gets [ __ ] personal
you gotta remember this is your job
don't take [ __ ] personal
and once you cross that line that's when
it goes sideways that thing about not
making it personal i mean what what is
the relationship between newton
and and and the pueblos those two
institutions were just sort of like set
up yeah you know they they like
seriously and this is speaking from a
lot of guys and i talked to a lot of
guys in the neighborhood it was two
separated institutions like two separate
it was totally separated you know we
felt like
at some point as we got older and wiser
we knew that
you come as a rookie and if you get
assigned to the pueblos you're going to
move up
you get signed to the east side you're
going to move up and rank that was one
of the some of the stuff we were
starting to pick up on and notice why is
that like because
they just
went over there and kicked ass
we feel like they pounded on us you know
over there not just the pueblos the
villains and whatever else over there
that east side that whole east side area
you know what i'm saying and it was like
some statements made by other police you
know what i'm saying it kind of took us
there to understand that is there
anything that you can remember that
you've seen that you've like
back in the day that you've respected
that you saw the police do over there i
could say it was one officer that we all
know
and it was a little kid named simmy over
there man that was uh having brain
cancer and he was dying he only had a
certain amount of time to live
and i really didn't [ __ ] with this
officer because he talked too much like
i felt i think you know
and like when i first came back to the
scene
you know after my vacation and he didn't
know who i was so he was all the kind
trying to come talk to me
and i don't know i don't want to talk to
you i don't want to talk to none of
y'all i don't have nothing to say you
know so his statement was oh we got to
watch this guy you know if they don't
talk to the police you know they up to
something i don't want to talk to the
police i don't want to talk to you and
nobody else you know what i'm saying i'm
literally just coming from doing a bid
you know so we don't have [ __ ] to talk
about you know but it's crazy because
down the line
uh as the as it got so bad for him to
where he had to go to the hospital and
they keep him comfortable
i used to see this guy there probably
three four times a week crying like a
[ __ ] baby bro literally i'm talking
about tears in his guy eyes
and it [ __ ] man because i'm like holy
[ __ ] like
this dude gives a [ __ ] so it kind of
made me feel like
you know hey
maybe they all ain't so bad right you
know right so that was one of the
moments right there that i would
seriously
reconsider that every officer is a bad
officer bobby d he's i mean i love the
guy like a brother man he's got a
[ __ ] huge heart and you know taking
care of taking care of the kid there and
helping out and and he was that's who he
is yeah yeah he was getting frustrated
because he didn't do it for attention he
doesn't do [ __ ] for attention he does it
because it's
that's who he is
and um when it started gathering a
little bit of attention and of course
you know the [ __ ]
once nebraska as a whole the upper
command staff they want to [ __ ] take
pictures and take credit and and [ __ ]
bobby was getting pissed off you know
and he's like i'm not doing it for that
because he truly cared you know and like
you say man you know he's he'll talk you
to death
he'll [ __ ] absolutely sit there and
talk you to death man but he's got a
good [ __ ] heart you know we're
getting older man
you know we're getting older
[ __ ] some of this [ __ ] doesn't matter
anymore it's like hey man let's just be
[ __ ] good people man
and um
i didn't i don't think i ever ran into
bow there i mean i might have you know
you mean on the streets on the streets
years ago but like i said the pueblos
wasn't my thing i like being over the
east side so we'd go over there when
something would happen
but um the first time i think we
actually talked was over at the
warehouse you know and
and
part of that thing of getting older and
and
you know you [ __ ] respect people no
matter what until they [ __ ] give you
something
to not respect him for you know knowing
you as well as i do and then getting to
know bo and then like there's no way you
guys wouldn't find love for each other
because i feel like you guys hold the
same principles true that you've got to
mean what you say and say what you mean
that you care about your communities you
care about your families i'm curious to
how you guys feel like the state of
policing is today and you you know crime
right now and and and the ability to to
have crime enforcement you know what
what what are your guys thoughts on that
well you know i'm one that and i'm
serious i don't give a [ __ ] who don't
like it i'm not one for defunding the
police man but i think that
it's a bunch of [ __ ] because man like at
some point they are needed bro
they are you know but i think that they
need to fix a lot of issues inside their
cells
they got to attend to the gangs inside
the game
you see what i'm saying
and i think that that like
i can't don't i don't have a solution i
want i wouldn't try to become a solution
but i think at some point like i said
our ambassador [ __ ] was doing
at some point let us police a lot of
things in our neighborhood because some
[ __ ] can be defused and you ain't even
got to get out your car
you know what i'm saying let us handle
it now it's [ __ ] that where it's going
to have to be attended to
attend to it and and what i've seen when
relationships are formed and you know
people in the neighborhood the way that
you used to police and the way that what
we're talking about with deemer we have
to both celebrate and look at people who
are doing it right because i i think my
problem i think what we're really guilty
of in this country is the wrong people
are sort of leading this charge it's
people who have never really been in
high crime communities are saying hey we
don't need the police anymore well maybe
you don't need the police because you've
never been in these kinds of communities
i i think it there there needs to be
go-to people in every neighborhood if
you have those people in place that you
can go to
they go back they're respected within
their homeboys and everything and we're
you know we're respected with our guys
like hey man let us give us five minutes
man let us [ __ ] squash this [ __ ]
before it goes sideways man i literally
literally seen
police
put [ __ ] on people arrest them and give
them a case
you know it's not just me getting my ass
whooped it's what i seen i know a dude
who got a double life sentence
on the murders that he wasn't even there
and the reason
we knew he wasn't there because he was
with 10 other people in a dice game when
this [ __ ] happened
the [ __ ] happened in one part of the
neighborhood it's like 10 people right
here in the [ __ ] dice game on the
porch
so when somebody came and said hey man
some [ __ ] happened over there y'all
better go
everybody left and the man went to jail
for a double life sentence wasn't even
there
swear to god
and i swear to you on my kid's life
was nowhere didn't we didn't even know
it happened
so it's a [ __ ] up situation all the
way around 100 percent you know and and
like i say it's hard just like for them
it's hard to trust totally it's hard to
trust that's right so they keep a
distinction man because you know you you
seeing this [ __ ] you're like [ __ ] what
if that happened to me then you you get
this this
narrative in your mind where at night if
this happens if they try to do me i'm
gonna do this i'm a whole court on the
street i'm gonna do the [ __ ] that at
some point i ain't gonna keep taking
this [ __ ] man you know and it get like
that you know
and even probably what they said
but you know but i'm thinking like the
[ __ ] that i didn't see man but i just
seen it on more than one occasion man
you know what i'm saying so that's why
it's it's really really so hard you know
what i'm saying it's really really sore
and a lot of them still to this point
today don't give a [ __ ] if it is a
relationship you know where it could be
some cool [ __ ] bo you're gonna go
through your life bro and there's gonna
be a certain percentage that's like [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] man i ain't i ain't
trusting that you know
i've lived that life man yeah
and i was in that struggle for a while
yeah
with the officer that you know no i know
we both thought this [ __ ] for
some reason man was on my [ __ ] yeah and
he wanted to convict me for murder
he wanted to how did you know the murder
because he told me he kicked in my door
took me to the man they ran up in my
house kicked in and you know and had me
in the station telling me this come on
man get the [ __ ] out of here like you
know whatever yeah and do what you got
to do you know
yeah you know and and and you know and
every time it got to the point to where
i didn't give a [ __ ] when i see him
because every time i seen him then he
had the rest of the police officers on
my [ __ ] you know every time i made a
move you know that was and he'll pull up
just real simple and [ __ ] with me and
talk [ __ ] you know and there again
there's the personal side of it man
you're like what the [ __ ] is the beef
man
you know
yeah and i i talked to him about it and
he's like
oh [ __ ] man there's there's something in
there dude he just won't tell me you
know and it's
i'm not gonna make excuses for him the
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens man you know
again it's personal
but
exactly you can convict that dude from
being a murderer thank you now the
evidence is right there in your [ __ ]
face right what the [ __ ] is you owe me
for because this is what he felt he felt
like i'm supplying a whole bunch of
doping [ __ ] over there and and trying to
make the blood car strong
you know and like i'm i'm trying to make
the blood car strong and all this and
i'm working with the mexicans and and
everything you know they working through
me and [ __ ] like that was his big thing
right there man you know and he felt
like he wanted that [ __ ] up out of there
you know what i'm saying and so he had
his bandana with me like now you know my
name came up oh possible whatever okay
you kicked in my door you took me in you
tried to [ __ ] um
uh arrest me for it all it didn't work i
walked out the station the same day
you know what i'm saying look man what
the [ __ ] you keep [ __ ] with me for
you know what i'm saying but that's the
[ __ ] and that's the [ __ ] that the other
officers
brooks man i'm not gonna yeah yeah no
and he started coming with the [ __ ] and
all you know like and then now you got
all these [ __ ] that finally
until they found something to you know
throw me away with an old ass [ __ ]
case and some [ __ ] that i didn't
even get arrested by the affairs with
the first time
and that's what i understand these guys
we'll bring this guy in i go what do you
got you got something on can we book him
can we book him tonight for this
whatever you want to say attempt murder
murder whatever can we book this cat
tonight
oh he's going to talk
[ __ ] he's not going to talk man
come on
no just bring him in we bring him in
[ __ ] you know he'd be there an hour and
we'd see him walking out the door
like okay well you just [ __ ] yourself
because you threw all your cards on the
[ __ ] table and you ain't got [ __ ]
when they was in the hood for some and
they were running through the hood and
they putting this little thing on oh
where both jingles at and you know you
you know and so i'm getting all these
phone calls and [ __ ]
you know that that person is riding
through the neighborhood tell them your
name you add and all that so you know
what i did
i went straight to the police station
that same day and i said i'm here so i
asked for him and he came i said man i
heard you was looking for me
i ain't looking for you oh you ain't
been running through the neighborhood
talking about where i'm at and all that
[ __ ] i mean what you thought it was
gonna put me make me hide or some [ __ ]
no i'm gonna bring it to you right what
oh well
they asked me some questions about
something that even
had nothing to do with that look man
come on i'm out of here the game you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah so
you know i left so i'm not running i'm
not gonna hide i'm not gonna do none of
that [ __ ]
but you for some reason you was really
convinced on this man you know what i'm
saying and it was crazy because that led
up to me getting arrested like three
more times for getting in confrontations
with officers where i i kind of say i
got all i didn't get you know
the normal beat down like you know what
i'm saying but it was just like whatever
now you know you grabbed me i'm not i'm
snatching and i'm not feeling just keep
letting y'all do this [ __ ] right you
know i'm saying i had three arrests but
all the rest was like you know
d.a rejects dismissed you know yeah just
because you know yeah but it's because
i'm sick of this [ __ ] you know and
that's what it what it was leading up to
to the point to where it was going to
turn into some danger and you know
you know my time away gave me time to
you know
change my attitude and my thoughts man
but you know like jerry i mean you you
you were ambushed
by a gang you know shout out your
partner was shot you know what i mean uh
1993 where uh me and my partner mendoza
were we went down we had grabbed a kid
from east coast for some
some water he had some pcp
and we were taking him back up and going
through the broadway hood
um
saw this one cat man this like i said
told you before man this guy should have
played
pro ball fast as [ __ ] man
never catch it i didn't even try to
catch him man you know i'm like man the
first time this dude booked it he was up
over the fence with you know one step
and he was over the fence on that man
ain't never gonna catch that cat the
only time he got him was when he ran
into his house and got him in his house
like so
um but he always had you know he always
carried a gun on him
rolling down the street
and this uh this base head i always
talked to man he was nervous as [ __ ]
right and because i was sitting just
chat with him for a second he's like oh
man i gotta go when he bones out right
now the [ __ ] was that about so my
partner's in the back seat
you know we had the the unmarked cars
and so my partner's behind me and the
rusties and the in the right size so we
roll up and i see these cats i see
homeboy
kind of standing on the sidewalk there
and i'm rolling in
and i start to slow down and here comes
the shirt man
he grabs a shirt
and he grabs his pistol
well at the same time
a guy never saw he was hiding between a
a g-ride and his garage
and he just starts [ __ ] lighting it
up he's got a 44 mag ruger shooting up
the the shooting up shooting at us so
he's shooting at my partner
so
i mean it takes you a second like [ __ ]
something what the [ __ ] is going on here
because i'm i'm focusing on this guy in
front of me
so then all of a sudden we see this cat
so he's blazing away so i start shooting
at him my partner is shooting at him
in the meantime the guy that we
initially saw
he's got a 40 cal and a 10 millimeter so
he's shooting
with both hands
and then another broadway's up on the
porch and he's got nine and he's
shooting
so
we end up dropping the one guy that
first started shooting
and then once he goes down
i swing my attention the other guy and
for whatever reason i cracked the door
right
i don't know man in my mind am i gonna
go out and go after him because he's
starting to [ __ ] boogie
and so that's when my partner goes i'm
hit i'm hit get me the [ __ ] out of here
so
throwing gear the rest is screaming
because i [ __ ] shot so
down the street to go i hit the corner
and uh
that's when i go to the back and i see
my partner man he's bleeding
you know he took one uh
right below the uh
the armpit hit a rib came out behind his
neck
and one of the rounds hit him in the
middle finger he was shooting back it
took a direct hit on the magazine in
front of the magazine wheel
and
took his finger off
one through the knee and then one
through his uh through his thigh area
so he got hit four times with the 44 and
the one that bounced off his
rib
i mean what is that one in a million hit
a rib and went out a different direction
otherwise he would have cleaned them out
in the center and then the guy in the
back seat he had one
went through the windshield under my arm
under my armpit through the seat and hit
him right in the right in the ten ring
but
you know going through the glass going
through the seat it slowed it down
enough to where they just they just
popped it out
and i think he got hit in the knee or in
the hand
and
me nothing
right so
get out
you know call the troops put out a help
call and everything one of the cars
rolls up and they grab uh
my partner
a guy you know one of the guys that was
after you for a while
they throw him in the police car and
they take him down to the fire station
on uh on main and main engage so
you know
he lived he was off for about a year and
a half lost his finger and
uh but you know it's like the whole
wrath of of newton division came down on
on broadway's for the next
you know
months
pretty much wiped them out there for a
while
and slowly they you know
slowly came back one other thing that
that's inspired me you know as much as
really anything in the last few years is
you know what you and shai built down
there and in terms of the theater
company and i just talked a little bit
about slauson wreck and how you see
giving back and the opportunities that
you're providing for folks down there
with shire man you know
awesome guy man you know and we're on a
set of tax collector man and um down the
line once you know after you there for
months with you with these people you
know y'all become family in there man
and he was one of the dudes that was
like really really cool you know and
and showed a lot of love to not just me
but my family
and so make no mistake about it every
person there
no matter what color they are is my
family over there and the way you handle
yourself over there man you know you you
you earned a whole lot of respect for me
and you know and he said man yeah i
appreciate that but we got to give
something back and then from there man
the guy kept his worry man and and we
just tried to just you know do this
experimental thing just try to you know
create something special to stay there
man you know and he was down with it 100
man and the the energy and and and
vitality and and uh just talent we ended
up all getting together and putting on
that uh that that reading man that you
start in and that you put that you got
the whole space together and you
organized and it was sort of this
beautiful
for me this beautiful event this thing
that i've been working on for 10 years
about this community in shreveport also
called the bottoms you know through art
through a sort of positive
creative endeavor you're bringing people
together in a way that look at that same
event you had cops there you had pueblos
there you had guys performing that had
never performed before and everybody did
great i think there's something about
these kind of creative endeavors that
brings folks together yeah i i mean it
was bishop but and then again too john i
mean i'm not gonna if you tell me
somebody's a good guy
i mean i know you long enough that
you're not gonna be [ __ ] with some
jackass yeah it's a [ __ ] just some
mouthpiece you know i know there's some
coppers that man here comes that
[ __ ] again you know and it's
just and some of the cops i couldn't
even stand but then some of the
gangsters out there too
and they would just you know want to
give you a hard time but as you get
older you mature and you're like [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] dude i'm just wanna have a
good time i'm gonna enjoy everybody's
company and we're just gonna talk man so
i mean we talked and [ __ ] we've talked
about [ __ ] going fishing and yeah
yeah i want to talk about that so yeah
man you know and that's the thing and
me and jerry talked and we talked about
where our mind state is now john and and
we know like me i know from my
neighborhood sometimes i got to be an
example to a point
to where everybody's not going to agree
with it and i say that to say
there was this thing going on where they
had the ambassador thing going
i forgot to do that soledad thing uh it
was something they called where um
the suns was it the sunburst yes
so anyway so what it was where um
they gave us jobs
so we did this thing where they try to
make it where your working hours was in
the neighborhood
and so when it's stuff like people
double parked and all that [ __ ] like
that and you know the music up loud and
all that [ __ ] like that the officers are
coming to you and say hey bo you know
man come on man these dudes can't be
blocking all the traffic right here man
you know so instead of them just coming
out and blazing and you know and and and
we worked with that man and that [ __ ]
was kind of cool like it's a couple of
police officers i i kind of respect out
of that you know what i'm saying you
know and then in that you know that
that's that one officer you know he want
to exchange numbers look man look i
still respect him i can't do it yeah you
know you're an active officer and i'm
not
and also too jerry man look and it was a
wonderful thing what you did man opening
up your doors to get there because like
john say man we had guys that never ever
did that before and was so
fired up and anxious and and and when we
completed it and finished and the love
and respect that we got from the people
was there man you know that you know we
was really scrambling to try to find a
spot and that was doing the pandemic
yeah and you opened your doors and that
right there made me respect you a lot
man you know and then after talking to
you you know what i'm saying it's just a
whole another different level man so you
got a lot of love respect yeah boy i
mean i appreciate you bro and you know
like i said dude it's just we're too
[ __ ] grown man yeah and about that
[ __ ] is a side
and like i said man if [ __ ] it was a
job and you did your job and your job
was not get caught my job was to catch
you you know and but we never crossed
paths that i can [ __ ] remember man
what do you like about fishing what does
it mean to you man man it's just [ __ ]
i'm out there in the boat
out in nature doing [ __ ] that man my dad
my uncles used to take me when we were
little and i was gonna take a break from
from work i was gonna take a leave of
absence because i had qualified to go
back east
uh and do tournament fishing yeah and so
i was trying to make that decision
and i'm like man that's going to be a
tough a tough road you know
[ __ ] man you know it's a big decision i
got family i'm like man i can't you know
i can't do it can't do it so i still
fish competitively around you know
around here and stuff like that and i
love doing it man i just love going
traveling i've been to washington oregon
texas arkansas [ __ ] i've been
everywhere fishing and
and how about you man man you know
because john i i didn't do a lot of
fishing and stuff like that you know
what i'm saying
and so you know you now as you get older
in your age you got this bucket list man
so one of the things that i want to do
is
know how to fish so i can mess with my
grandkids yeah you know or even my kids
and you know whatever you know what i'm
saying and and get to really know what
i'm talking about yeah and i'm not
sitting there you know just waiting
because i know that if you can show them
different things man they'll really
appreciate it and respect it through
life you know what i'm saying and then
it could go somewhere with them you know
you don't know wherever they can go
somewhere well i mean next time we get
together we got to do it in a boat then
hey guys i i can't thank you and
honestly we could talk about that we
gotta
uh
i love both
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff and mean a lot to us i
hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself